Imagine I was holding a 1.5 volt battery
one of those batteries that
you put into a camera. One of the teeny ones.
And I ran four hundred miles of
wire from this battery down to Los Angeles.
This shark could sense the electrical
field off of that battery 400 miles away.
So this sense is 5 million times more
sensitive than any human sense. It is
by far the most sensitive sense we've ever
discovered on the planet. So the next time
you're swimming at the Dolphin Club,
you can remember that sharks aren't really
smelling you. They're honing in on your
electroreceptive field that is coming
off of your heart and brain waves.
So it was a pretty frightening thought
when I learned that. Because I surf
down at Ocean Beach all the time.
Anyway, sharks do it. Bees do it. Birds do it.
We probably do it, too. Humans have probably
been using some sort of magneto-receptive
sense for centuries. Ancient Polynesian
sailors could navigate hundreds of miles
across open ocean and usually always
make it back to the same exact spot.
Now they could use celestial navigation
for some of the time. Solar navigation for
some of that other time. But they couldn't
use both all of the times, especially during
stormy weather. So how did they do it?
Then there's these guys: the
Guugu Yimithirr, an Australian aboriginal tribe.
They incorporated cardinal directions
into their language. They didn't have
words for right, left, forward, or
backwards. But they did have words
for North, South, East, and West. If one of
these guys wanted you to make room
for him on a bench, he wouldn't ask you to
to move over to the right. He would ask you
to move south. They didn't bend backwards.
They bent eastwards or northwards.
The only way this group could communicate
was if they knew their exact position
on the globe at all times. Which is a
very hard thing to do at night and
a very hard thing to do in an
enclosed space. But they weren't alone
dozens and dozens of cultures also
used Cardinal languages. Just like these guys
the Tzeltal of central Mexico they again
didn't have words for right or left but
they had words for north south east and
west. In the 01990s a bunch of researchers
took one of these Tzeltal speakers and
placed him in a room. They blindfolded him
and they spun him around about
25 times and immediately asked them
to identify where north south east and west was.
This guy did it without any hesitation.
20 times in a row. And I
think they just gave up and moved on after that.
You know, thank God for the 70s:
here's a picture from some 70s
experiments. In the 70s and 80s, human
magneto reception was all the rage.
They conducted over 1,000 experiments in this
stuff and almost all the time people
who were blindfolded, twisted around,
magnets on their head, whatever, they were able
to point in their home direction. With
one exception. When the experimenters would
tape a little piece of magnetite
to their foreheads they lost all sense of
direction. Now researchers had done this
years before they had taken a turtle
and they had taken a bird, and taped...
I'm not talking about a kitchen magnet
I'm talking about a teeny teeny piece.
And it's really sad, if you ever see these
videos, because the turtles just kind of swim
in circles, lazily. They have no idea
how to make their way around.
Something interesting I saw a couple days ago,
the Nobel Prize in science just
went to some researchers that identified
something called the "internal GPS" within
cells. These cells are able to
activate and stay activated only when an
animal is facing in one particular
direction. Which is how we're able to
find our way around and remember where
we've gone. We don't know if these cells
are magneto receptive yet. But it
makes sense that they would be.
They're doing more research in that.
I know what you're thinking is like,
it seems impossible that we would have this sense
when we can't find our way out of a
shopping mall or parking lot.
The fact is we just don't need it today
too much. But we did need it
about 400 years ago, and before then.
This is what Manhattan was supposed to
look like about 400 years ago. You'd need
a pretty good sense of direction to make
it through here. And especially through
the heavily forested areas. This is what
Manhattan looks like now. You need zero
sense of direction to make it around
here. The pattern of settlements, roads and
other landmarks that undergrid
our modern society make it easy to
know exactly where we are.
And of course if ever we're in doubt
you pull out your phone. From practically
anywhere on the planet you can see
exactly where you are through GPS.